uh we have been hearing more and more
over the last several
weeks to month and a half or so
republicans in right-wing media pushing
the narrative of
a crisis at the border and a surge
in undocumented crossings last week we
covered house minority
leader republican congressman kevin
mccarthy
who staged an event at the u.s mexico
border
said unaccompanied minors are coming to
the u.s
in crisis levels and the crisis was
caused by joe biden
kevin mccarthy said that terrorists are
coming in
through the u.s mexico border from yemen
turkey and wait yemen turkey and iran
it was there was no actual evidence of
that but this is the narrative it's been
pushed by fox news reporters during
press briefings it's been pushed
in news reports it's been pushed by
republicans at press conferences
is this real well the washington post
analyzed border patrol data going back
to 2012
and there appears to be no crisis
whatsoever there is no
surge that we could link to biden
administration policy
what we are seeing is data that tracks a
seasonal pattern this is the time of
year
where there are more migrants attempting
to cross and interacting with border
patrol
plus some what we might call pent-up
demand
from the covet period last year when
movement was just dramatically reduced
so if we look at a chart of encounters
per month
at the border looking at the last few
years and we're putting that up on the
screen
what you see is that numbers went up at
exactly this time of year in 2019
they did not in 2020 because of the
pandemic
they went up slightly at this time in
2018
and that's the pattern it's a pattern
that's been observed for some time now
yes apprehended migrants are up 28
from january to february but apprehended
migrants were up 31
during the same period in 2019 it is
true
that the raw numbers are higher right
now than last year
and the year before remember movement
in general went down during the pandemic
so what you're seeing
number one right now is a resumption of
movement and number two some backed up
demand from people who did not move
around last year
now let me be very clear because i know
i'm going to get emails about this i'm
not saying we don't need total and
complete immigration reform we do
uh this doesn't mean that joe biden
has done enough to stop deportations he
hasn't
and i've talked about that it simply is
not the crisis that republicans want you
to think it is it's the crisis that
we've had in this country for a long
time
combined with a lack of comprehensive
immigration reform which i and others
have been calling for
for just as long of a time what trump
did last year with title 42
which is using the pandemic as a reason
um
to turn people around and deport
it seems to have delayed people from
coming
not stopped people from coming period
that's the story
many of them are coming now not because
joe biden is president
but because the pandemic is to some
degree easing almost identical to joe
biden's
surge in gas prices last week which we
covered earlier this week
we are seeing gas prices go up it's not
because of joe biden
they started going up in october when
donald trump was still president
and what we're seeing is demand for
gasoline
recover as the pandemic starts to ease
it has nothing to do with joe biden so
serious media should really just report
this
based on facts but without using the
language that the right uses you know
when you talk about border crisis it's
sort of like
sleepy joe and china virus these are
terms that the right uses to frame the
debate in a particular way
where you're no longer questioning
whether there is a border crisis
you're merely arguing as to whose fault
it is and
to what degree it exists and this is how
the right
does really well at framing issues it
keeps republican voters enraged
it doesn't really allow solutions to the
problems however
so call it a predictable seasonal
pattern that we've observed for a decade
bolstered by the waning of coronavirus
to some degree
and um even non like what we
even what we would call non-right-wing
media
is using a lot of the terms of the right
when they talk about this and as i've
talked about before using their
don't let them even set the agenda and
narrative by using the language and
that's what they
successfully have done on so many issues
for decades as we've talked about with
people like
george lake often thomas frank here on
the program so don't fall for it
here's the data the data's clear um and
and we're going to continue to track
that data tomorrow friday
finally the day is here the one day
david pakman show membership special we
are doing a massive blowout of
memberships we're hoping for massive
membership
dumps tomorrow if you want to be
notified
of a one day i i hesitate to even say
that it's a moral discount i believe the
discount we're offering tomorrow is
immoral it's vaccine themed if you want
to be notified tomorrow morning
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's
a practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video